so uh senator rand paul got into a
massive blowout
with dr fauci over covid this morning so
this has just happened in the last hour
or so
we're gonna show you about a three
minute clip here and originally when i
pulled the clip
i wanted to maybe cut it a little bit
you'll see a flash or two in there
but basically i wanted to give you guys
three minutes of really
listen to what the debate is really
listen like i know it's a little bit
technical and i'll
i'll give you the full definition of
what gain of function is after
but really listen to what rand paul is
accusing
dr fauci of and then listen to what dr
fauci says
in a response it's quite extraordinary
and i would just paint one other thing i
don't i don't want to color your
impression of this too much but
especially towards the end listen to how
rand paul is using a lot of bureaucratic
language
instead of giving just a clear answer
did we fund gain a function
uh list you know just listen to how
fauchy is sort of obfuscating
what the answer might be all right take
a look dr falchi
as you are aware it is a crime to lie to
congress
section 1001 of the u.s criminal code
creates a felony and a five-year penalty
for lying to congress
on your last trip to our committee on
may 11th
you stated that the nih has not ever and
does not now fund gain and function
research in the wuhan institute of
virology
and yet gain of function research was
done entirely in the wuhan institute
by dr xi and was funded by the nih
in this paper dr she credits the nih
and lists the actual number of the grant
that she was given by the nih
in this paper she took two bat
coronavirus
jeans spike genes and combined them with
a sars related backbone
to create new viruses that are not found
in nature
these lab created viruses within to
shown to replicate in humans
these experiments combine genetic
information from different coronaviruses
that infect
animals but not humans to create novel
artificial viruses able to infect human
cells
viruses that in nature only infect
animals
were manipulated in the wuhan lab to
gain the function
of infecting humans this research fits
the definition
of the research that the nih said was
subject to the pause in 2014 to 2017
a pause in funding on gain of function
the wuhan lab used nih funding to
construct
novel chimeric sars-related
coronaviruses
able to infect human cells and
laboratory animals
this is high-risk research that creates
new
potential pandemic pathogens potential
pandemic pathogens that exist
only in the lab not in nature
this research matches these are dr
ebright's words
this research matches indeed epitomizes
the definition of gain of function
research done
entirely in wuhan for which there was
supposed to be a federal pause
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11th where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wuhan senator paul
i have never lied before the congress
and i do not retract that statement
this paper that you were referring to
was
judged by qualified staff up and down
the chain
as not being gained a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase this transability to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function yeah that is correct
and and senator paul you do not know
what you are talking about
quite frankly and i want to say that
officially
you do not know what you are talking
about
okay you get one person let's read from
the nih can i
function is that the the grant that was
funded
as a sub award from eco health to wuhan
created sars kovi ii that's where you
are getting
let me finish we don't know wait a
minute it didn't come in the lab but
all the evidence is pointing that it
came from the lab and there will be
responsibility for those who funded the
lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the witness to
reach i totally resent
the lie that you are now propagating
senator
because if you look at the viruses
that were used in the experiments
that were given in the annual reports
that were published in the literature it
is molecularly
impossible no one's saying those viruses
those virus caused the pandemic what
we're alleging is that gain of function
research was going on in that lab
and nih funded it that is get away from
it it meets your definition
and you are obfuscating the truth okay
so i hope you guys understand why i
showed you the full clip there because
you can sort of see fouchy at the end
trying to well we
funded this and the paper that did this
that the other thing he's giving you a
lot of bureaucratic stuff there so
previously he had actually said
that the nih the national institute of
health never funded
gain of function research in the wuhan
lab
rand paul is now saying that is exactly
what you did
and we have evidence of it so i can't
sit here and tell you that i know which
the truth is on that fauchi saying well
how she's not exactly saying they didn't
do it anymore right
he's just saying the funding may have
went to something else that was
like sort of ancillarily involved but
not exactly
so let's just pause on that for a second
just let's just be clear about one thing
rand paul's making a very specific
accusation the nih
funded gain of function research
in the woohen lab that's the accusation
fouchy
last time he was under oath and that's
why rand paul worded it the way he did
last time
he was under oath said that's absolutely
untrue this time he didn't quite exactly
say that but i thought i'd give you guys
a clean
definition of what gain of function is
rand paul explained it i thought quite
well but i thought
if i could just give you the cleanest
possible explanation because this is all
technical stuff
i'm not an expert in this i know you're
not an expert in this but we need to
know
we need to know like some basics about
this right so when you have a
conversation with friends and family
and they're talking about all of this
stuff and lab leaks and everything else
that you have some
ability to communicate some of this
stuff so gain of function research
involves experimentation that aims or is
expected to
and or perhaps actually does increase
the transmissibility
and or virulence of pathogens such
research when conducted by responsible
scientists
usually aims to improve understanding of
disease-causing agents
their interactions with human hosts and
or their potential
to cause pandemics despite these
important potential benefits
uh benefits gain of function research
can pose risks
regarding biosecurity and biosafety so
basically they meddle with
these viruses and then the argument that
rand paul's making is then
it can basically jump to humans and then
if that then
leaks out of the lab we have a problem